this is the one
that we
noticed live while we were spinning 50
different plates on the air on sunday as
the saints buccaneers game was ending
and nbc's football night in america was
unfolding michael thomas got rolled up
on by teammate alvin kamara
and
the initial indication i got was not
encouraging he was walking around like
oh i'm fine i'm fine and wouldn't let
the trainers look at it and then
everything got very quiet anytime that
happens
that tells you there's a problem right
and then we hear high ankle sprain but
he's going to try to play through it and
chris we talked about this earlier in
the week high ankle sprain play through
it
that's not the kind of thing you can
play through and now the report
surprisingly not that michael thomas is
expected to miss several weeks with this
high ankle sprain because of course he
will because of course that's what
happens when you have a high ankle
sprain yeah that's right and you know
this is this is the other factor that
plays into this it's the type of injury
one that you know after you do it you
think okay you know man it hurts but i i
think i'll be okay in a few days and you
wake up the next morning and it's 10
times worse and so that's the first
thing you might think the night of the
injury like i'll be okay in a week i
think i might be able to do this but
then it really sets in the other thing
that sets in too and where players might
walk around in the locker room after the
game and all of that we've had this
conversation toradol tore toradol's
still misleading up to like 24 hours
after the game because it's a numbing
drug it's a numbing agent so guys get
hurt and this is why we see more serious
injuries than not sometimes because they
don't realize how badly they are hurt
until the next day until the toradol
wears off so with all that i bet his
ankle is very sore and
he plays a position that you know the
ankle is kind of important to be able to
stick your foot in the ground cut off at
it you know at 100
speed or whatever that may be
jamming it in the ground change
directions do that
michael michael thomas is a big guy and
he is very good at sticking his foot in
the ground and being a good route runner
and i would think that's even more of a
handicap for him because that's his game
and it's going to be really hard to
explode off that and you know take that
uh pounding from the body and and his
ability to drive force in the ground
of the limited nfl injuries to which i
can relate because i've suffered them a
sprained ankle is one but it was a low
ankle sprain and it hurt like hell for a
couple of days and then it was fine and
it's just fine like the swelling goes
down it's like hey it doesn't hurt
anymore like i'm preparing myself that
this is going to be a source of pain and
discomfort and limitation for weeks but
it was a low ankle sprain yeah it's time
for sprain a different one all together
and we always hear four to six weeks and
we'll see how long michael thomas is out
but it hurts the saints this is a guy
who had 149 receptions last year a guy
who aspired to have even more
this year he only had two
week one now he's gonna miss several
weeks he has to along with everything
else come to terms with the fact that
he's not getting anywhere close to 149
this year yeah right and that's
and i feel bad for him he's an intense
individual he is a focused and driven
player and he's a great player and now
after the first game of the season
you've got to process all of this stuff
anger denial bargaining depression and
acceptance that's why it took a few days
i think for the report to come out
that he's going to miss several weeks i
think he doesn't want to accept the fact
and my guess is he's going to do
everything in his power to get on the
field they you know this is a perfect
year
to have the three-week injured reserve
option aimed at maximum roster
flexibility chris because
the best way to protect michael thomas
from himself self-protect him from
himself is to put him on injured reserve
yeah you're right
anything i've never met michael thomas
you can see the intensity when he plays
football you could see he loves the
sport you could see that he backs down
from no one and then i think we both
heard from people in new orleans that he
is that guy he he works hard as hell
doesn't matter who's in front of him i
remember sean payton making the
statements last year about michael
thomas beating him up in drills when he
was coming off the line of scrimmage and
all that stuff so very intense and
probably the most important piece of the
new orleans saints offense i mean
there's no other way to sugarcoat it
he's won the most important piece
because so much of the pass game is
around him and what he can do
and then it's a like a double whammy
to where he's so important to the scheme
and sean payton and his ability but he's
also extremely important to drew brees i
mean he's drew brees crutch but so much
of what sean payton creates with michael
thomas is the type of throws that drew
brees is good at and capitalizing at so
now okay who's gonna be that guy no
one's gonna be as talented and it'll be
easier to take away those type of throws
which could also be a ripple effect to
go oh no now brees might have to make
throws that you know we question and
it's fair to question i think after week
one his arm didn't exactly look like
top-notch to me and that's where i worry
about the saints there and sean payton's
gonna have to find a kind of a new
formula to make this offense go
there was an intensity in michael thomas
before their playoff win over the eagles
in january of 2019 that was stunning to
me
and and and and was inspiring at the
same time he was so fired up for that
game and that's what he brings to the
table and as you're trying to process
this if you're michael thomas i think
what you have to do is say okay fine
look the ultimate goal is still on the
table and that's to finally get back to
the super bowl for him it's get there
for the first time for sean payton and
drew brees let's get back i think
they're the only ones everyone else it's
a first time experience but they've been
pounding on the door every year 2017
2018 2019 all years michael thomas was
with the new orleans saints and i think
it's a refocus now forget about
individual accolades forget about
regular season record forget about
regular season accomplishment get
healthy get ready to come back and help
the team in the post season and you may
have to help the team get to the
postseason based on what happens without
him i'm looking at the depth chart and
we know the depth chart isn't set in
stone in part because teams go out of
their way to tell us it's not set in
stone which makes me wonder why the hell
they even
publish depth charts that's not going to
be one of my grievances that gets aired
later it's just a standing irritation
that i have but marquez calloway
undrafted rookie out of tennessee as
listed as the backup to michael thomas
yeah now i don't know whether that means
he gets more reps trey quan smith is
behind emmanuel sanders deontay harris
is listed on the depth chart as well
this team's got five receivers right on
the depths
so they're gonna they need somebody yeah
michael thomas isn't able to play they
got to do something bump somebody off of
the practice squad sign a free agent
mohammed sununu not available he signed
with the 49ers yesterday as expected
trade for somebody we'll be talking
about that coming up soon but he's got
to do something sean payton does along
with gm mickey loomis to deal with
michael thomas's absence if he is gone
for a few weeks because i don't know
that bumping up marquez calloway
traequan smith or deontay harris to the
number one receiver spot is going to be
the answer no it's not and that's why
you know that's twofold of why he's so
important to the offense too you're
seeing there so all the things we
mentioned plus they have nothing they're
a little weak in the wide receiver
department hey emmanuel sanders is a
good player but he's not a superstar
he's not talented the way he was four or
five years ago to attract attention that
way and hey marquez callaway he might
get a few more reps mike but just to
answer that question like i would be
shocked if i saw him in the michael
thomas role that role is just
it takes a special football player with
great experience great football
knowledge and knowing how to read
defenses playing that little slot
position in the sean payton west coast
offense i would think now you're going
to have a little bit more of a you know
by committee approach to take over for
the michael thomas stuff where yes uh
and emmanuel sanders gets involved in
the conversation a little bit because
he's been around the block a few times
he'll understand like oh when the
defense does this drew expects me to do
that and all of those type of
intricacies that are in the offense that
i don't know if i would trust with a
young guy and you might see a traequan
smith and things like that uh dabble in
there but they're going to have to be
creative he's going to have to extend
the jared cook part of his playbook and
probably the alvin kamara maybe motioned
out of the backfield use him in the
passing game more i would expect those
to be kind of the next moves uh for sean
payton
yeah that was going to be our next point
the idea that sean payton will take the
various chess pieces he has and move
them around in his offense because he
values flexibility jared cook can go out
to the slot alvin kamara can move around
remember they have time montgomery who
was a receiver who became a running back
that's right the green bay packers once
upon a time so oh yeah and they also
have taysom hill so you know they've got
guys who can pick up the slack in that
offense but michael thomas the straw
that stirs the drink to borrow a phrase
from stephen jones as it related to
ezekiel elliott last year before his
hold out now the injury to michael
thomas it's going to be an issue for the
saints but of all the coaching staffs
out there sean payton's is the one that
probably can figure out how to deal with
it the best and and find another way to
make that offense hum even if michael
thomas is unavailable for several weeks
uh and
i i think it would be
i think it would be rash to trade for
somebody and if they would trade for
somebody it tells you it's more than
just a couple of weeks see that's why
they don't want to tell us anything
about injuries folks i know we get
irritated you got a fantasy lineup you
got to worry about you got a team that
you're rooting for you want to know are
the players going to play you have
gambling interests that you may want to
pursue do i take the points do i give
the points do i take the saints do i go
over do i go under and you want to know
if guys are going to play they don't
want us to know because
if all of a sudden the saints are faced
with a more extensive absence by michael
thomas to the point where they're
thinking about trading for somebody they
don't want the team they'd be doing the
deal with to think they're desperate no
that's exactly right they want to be
able to say yeah we really don't need
and michael tom is going to be back in a
couple weeks but you know if this guy's
disgruntled maybe we'll do it that's a
far different approach to the bargaining
table then oh man we got to get this guy
we got to get this guy can we have this
guy can we get this guy what do we need
to do what do we need to do tell us tell
us tell us so that's why they don't want
to tell us anything about injuries so
one of the many reasons why they don't
want to tell us you're right and and i
don't think you know i wouldn't expect
the saints in this situation to quite
dabble in the trade market yet
probably go out see a game or two of
what we got
and see where michael thomas is after
two weeks if he's gonna be back in the
third week all right yeah four weeks
there's no no need to panic but if you
go through two or three games and you go
whoa
man our offense we we stink we're
struggling and michael thomas man he
might be back you know after four weeks
but it's not looking good he's not going
to be 100 then they might have to make
moves i don't know dez bryant is out
there on the street they did work him
out at one time uh he was on the team he
was on the team yeah a couple years ago
so maybe they revisit that i got to look
at the list of free agent receivers out
there that would make sense but i would
think for now they're going to make do
with what they got i know go ahead say
it i knew you there's a guy available in
a few weeks yeah there's a he's
available to be signed now he's just not
available to play until after his team
has played its eighth game or eight
weeks of the regular season pass they
can handle
they brought him in for a workout not a
workout a visit last year because and i
think sean payton and this is part of
that little
devilish in a good way the good trouble
as john lewis would say sean payton
trying to stir things up to get what
needs to be done
accomplished as it relates to the nfl
and some of the rules and some of the
regulations some of the way things
happen sure antonio brown is kind of
back burnered they're not making a
decision so hey let's bring him in for a
visit let's maybe push this thing
forward let's maybe get this thing done
let's force the nfl's hand i feel like
that's what they were doing last year
and if they see something they like in
antonio brown and he could probably do a
better job of replacing michael thomas's
production than anyone they have on the
roster
something to consider if it's more than
just a couple of weeks chris yeah i mean
he certainly would be able to fill that
role in a lot of ways he's you know
again another guy that's been around the
block he'll understand what's being
taught what's being asked of of that
position and of course you know he's a
he's a talented football player i don't
think he's going to be the guy we
remember him to be but
you know to your point yes i don't know
if there's anybody on the roster even
though i haven't seen antonio brown play
football in a year i feel pretty safe to
say that he's still better than
everybody on the the wide receiver the
wide receivers on the saints other than
michael thomas
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports